I'd like to welcome you to this panel
discussion on predicting elections this
is a a public event that's being
sponsored by the program for economic
research which is a research wing at the
Economics Department here at Columbia my
name is Naveen Karthik I'm a professor
in the Economics Department and I will
be the moderator for for this evening
I'm delighted that we have a very
distinguished panel a set of panelists
here with us but before I introduce them
let me just say a couple of words about
the topic and then and then let them
delve into the details the the word
prediction as some of you might be aware
comes from a a conjunction of two Latin
terms pray which means before and dhikr
a which means to say and I would guess
that that people have been interested in
forecasting or predicting events before
they actually occur presumably since
since the dawn of mankind we all make
predictions of some sort in in every
aspect of our daily lives from things as
mundane to the weather be like today
will the subway be on time will I get
stuck in traffic how long will it take
me to get to work and and so on these
are these are obviously not very
important issues and in the larger
scheme of things and so most of us don't
acquire fame or notoriety through making
these predictions on the other hand
there are domains in which predictions
are extremely important of course and
one of them is that is the topic for
today which is about elections elections
are an important component of any
democracy while functioning democracies
offer voters or citizens the choices
viable choices over different
alternatives in which their their
opinions do matter this could include
things like choosing a president
choosing a legislature or it could be
voting on a referendum a ballot measure
and so on and these you know in cases
like this we care not only about what
the outcome of the election actually is
but it's also important that we be able
to predict this a
at some point in advance okay and and
this matters for lots of reasons
firms care about this in in in order to
guide what kinds of investment decisions
they make this affects stock market
performance this matters for parties
campaign strategies this you even hear
stories about how this affects people's
immigration decisions from certain
countries and so on okay
once you start thinking about this is
obviously a host of questions that come
to mind how do experts go about making
predictions for elections in particular
and predictions more generally for other
matters too is there a a method that's
that's the best method to use or or
should we be considering multiple
approaches and multiple sources of data
how well do experts actually do in terms
of their predictions how do we measure
the accuracy of expert predictions how
do we measure how well they do what
kinds of information should we be
gathering if we want to improve the
accuracy of forecasts or predictions as
society these are their some of the
questions that I think the panelists
will be taking on today and and
certainly things that we will be able to
get get into during the question and
answer session later on so as I said we
we have a very distinguished set of
panelists I'm thrilled that all of them
have accepted to be here today let me
briefly tell you a little bit about
about each of them
Nate's over here on my left is the
author of a widely acclaimed book the
the signal and the noise that I even
just started reading and highly
recommend to you I actually gave it to
one of my undergraduates today as a
prize for a classroom experiment that we
ran in in class even if you haven't
heard of the book you probably have
heard about his political website
fivethirtyeight.com which is now hosted
by the New York Times or you might have
heard about his many contributions to
the analysis of baseball statistics with
his correct with the success incorrectly
calling various political races recently
I think it's probably fair to say that
he's become one of the leading public
faces of statistics in general and
political forecasting in particular to
his left is Professor Philip
clock who's currently the Annenberg
University professor at the University
of Pennsylvania previously he was the
Mitchell professor of business
psychology and political science at UC
Berkeley at the University of California
he's a fellow of the American Academy of
Arts and Sciences and is the author of
an award-winning book expert political
judgment how good is it how can we know
I gather that he's been studying experts
predictions for more than 30 years now
and it's surely one of academia as
foremost experts on experts professor
Justin Wolfers at the the far left is a
professor of public policy in economics
at the University of Michigan he was
previously a faculty at the University
of Pennsylvania he's currently an editor
of the Brookings papers on economic
activity many of you might have come
across his his numerous articles both at
The Wall Street Journal or on the
economics blog at the New York Times
he's the leading scholar on prediction
markets which I'm sure he will be
touching on today and as and has
explicitly researched different aspects
to forecasting elections okay so with
that by way of introduction I'd like to
turn it over to the panelists what I'd
like to do is invite them each to speak
for roughly 10 minutes or so initially
in turn and then after that we'll open
it up to questions and answers what I'd
like to do then is initially pose a few
questions myself for them to take on and
then after that we'll we'll open it up
at the audience at large
okay the order that we agreed upon for
for the initial comments that they make
is is nate silver followed by Justin
Wolfers and then Philip tetlock
so let me turn it over Nate the floor is
yours
great well thank you all for coming
today this is as far as I'm concerned
kind of an all-star panel that people
have done really terrific work and kind
of bring out the science in forecasting
both in elections more narrowly and
we're broadly and I wanted to speak very
very briefly at the top here kind of a
macro level 30,000 foot wait so if you
go in for example I I've started to read
the Harvard Business Review for for some
reason alive if you read this magazine
there are some good studies and some
dubious ones right but pretty much every
other advertisement in the magazine is
about about big data that this term that
we have all this information
it's become a very sexy topic travel
around and talk to two different
companies and two different
organizations and it worries me when we
have this new technology people don't
really know how to use it very much it's
a lot like my dad using Twitter for
example where you get some good results
but but if you guys follow my dad on
Twitter but you know there's a lot of
noise there as well from time to time
but if you look back at the work that
that Justin and Phil have done
prediction is is hard especially about
the future if you look at areas like
like economic forecasting for example
like like earthquake forecasting like
forecasting the spread of infectious
disease there have been a lot of false
positives so to speaks a lot of failure
to to improve things we have very little
ability now to make forecasts still of
economic growth more than about six
months in advance and so really people
want to tell the story about a Moneyball
where everything came together and now
baseball's been revolutionized by by
stats that story is only partially true
to one for one thing but also that's
really kind of an exceptional case where
in baseball you can define what it means
to make a good forecast where you
measure success by wins and losses there
is some noise there there is some random
so the short term but you have good
incentives you have a very competitive
market you have a lot of things in place
that that allow quantitative analysis
succeed there in in most fields you have
one or more limiting factors and
limiting factors is a polite way of
saying that you know that we might have
a lot of data but we're still pretty
dumb sometimes I think the second point
is just the importance of a prediction
and forecasting to science in general
you can take the view that that a theory
is not scientific unless it's testable
or verifiable prediction is maybe the
easiest way to verify things so I get
suspicious sometimes when there are
people who say well I have well the
couple things I get suspicious of number
one is when someone will fit a model to
to pass data that works wonderfully with
the day that you're building the the the
the the model from but doesn't make
predictions very well at all there's
kind of a class of problems called
overfitting
for example that produce
false-positives this is a very serious
problem with with social science
researchers just kind of scientific
research in general I think a lot of
people don't really grasp that that
fitting a model is really a form of
history kind of in a quantified way in
not really a form of a prediction per se
prediction is most valuable when when
you are operating under actual
uncertainty when you say something the
word
predict means you say something in
advance then you test it on an unknown
piece of data it's a very important part
of hypothesis testing and so it's so
that deserves a lot more attention and
the third and related point is just that
although we have a lot of data in a lot
of different fields right now we don't
have a lot of data except for the work
that people like dr. dr. headlock have
done on on how well experts are on how
well forecasters are doing the
macro-level studies of weather
prediction is working or not what
techniques tend to work or not seems
like it's that we should be devoting a
lot more resources to instead of course
there are various reasons for this one
of which is that people don't want to
test themselves I find myself as I've
had reputation for more success right
and become a lot more cautious myself I
understand those those incentives right
you don't want to kind of be goofy and
put yourself dial in and predict the
Super Bowl people make fun of you if you
get it wrong but there's also a problem
where people still see prediction is
being kind of this mystical and mythical
thing where where David Brooks for
example referred to people who are using
data to predict election campaigns as
Wizards infamously these since praise
dr. Jeff Locke's burg so maybe he'll
come around eventually but it really is
a type of science a complicated type of
science that we need to think about best
practices in and we need to train people
in a lot more that starts with probably
better math and science education where
you focus more on teaching stats and
probability going all the way back to
elementary schools and middle schools
and high schools it's it's a big problem
and so I'm kind of a near-term pessimist
about how much progress big data will
produce and a long term optimist about
this being a part of technological and
economic growth in a long run but
probably with some false starts in but
you know even 538 for example was seen
as a example where we had a lot of
success with taking data relative to
elections but the model that I use for
538 is is in essence pretty simple
whereas just averaging the polls
together and then counting to 270
meaning does one can't have a majority
of states an electoral college and then
trying to account for the uncertainty in
that in the problem how much how much
error there is in the estimate and yes
there is more detail than that we'll
talk about some of that detail but even
relatively simple systems like
RealClearPolitics that just were taking
an average of polls they got 48 or 49 or
in some cases 50 states right as 538 did
and the fact that the Cocina so amazing
was so controversial I thought was
actually kind of a bad sign really you
know taking an average of a bunch of
polls and saying that Obama's ahead in
Ohio he'll probably win is not nearly as
complex as forecasting the weather or or
the economy you were or how well a
medical intervention might work or what
we should do for our education system
and and that caused so much
consternation I really kind of thought
of it as a sign that we have a long way
to go still so hopefully I can make a
tiny bit of progress we're thinking
about this in a more healthy and
responsible way so thank you okay Justin
great so let me also be brief I want to
ask four questions and then partly when
I have fun occasionally at Nate's
expense so the first question is why is
Nate solver so good what can we learn
from that the second question is is nate
silver any good
third question is can you do better than
nate silver and then the fourth question
is how we can is is really what the what
what what's the future polling and how
we can do better so why is nate silver
so good at forecasting elections he
actually just described it what he's
doing is actually incredibly simple it's
based on I think three observations
looking at many polls is better than
looking at one poll it's kind of obvious
figuring out whether a poll is biased is
better than just taking it at face value
it's kind of obvious and polling is not
the only information that we have and so
you need to take account of other
information and uncertainty as well it's
also kind of obvious in fact much of
what Nate's doing and he's been explicit
about this and much of his work has been
happening in political science from the
early 90s onwards Bob Erickson's here
tonight bob was a pioneer in this Andrew
Gelman also from the political science
department you can find much of the
genesis that the 538 model in in in the
work that's occurred in the political
science department here
why then is night such a wizard and I
think here the big insight is Phil
tetlock
it turns out everyone else is so bad
so Phyllis has shown has demonstrated
that experts are terrible and so Nate
figured out all he has to do is not be
an expert and so he follows the numbers
rather than his gut and the very very
simple rules of elementary statistics
that I laid out at the start and that's
a huge insight so all he has to do I
really think if neighbors basically
demonstrating the flip side of a filter
looks dictum that experts are terrible
all you have to do is not do what
they're doing and you can think about
why experts are terrible and here you
put on the Economist hat there very few
incentives to be right and in fact many
incentives to the contrary so the people
you see on CNN are either raving
Democrats who always see Democrats are
on the cusp of winning or they're
Republicans who always say they're on
the Republicans are on the cusp of
winning or their pollsters who are
always saying the Gallup poll will be
right or PPP polls will be right or my
poll will be right
no one's ever actually got much of
incentive to look at truth they get very
very little feedback political pollsters
so they'd start off by talking about big
data but election forecasting is
actually a small data problem we only
get feedback once every four years if
you get to run one experiment every four
years it's gonna take you centuries to
learn anything the business model for
polling is very very different than the
model for say picking stocks almost
every pollster runs their political
polling as a loss leader as opposed to
say Wall Street analysts are actually
trying to win money for their firms in
some cases and then I think the other
thing tonight's great credit is actually
to do elementary statistics you have to
put together a database of polls and you
can't just download that off the
internet it actually had some real shoe
leather custom he's gone out and done
that work and so there's a broader
implication from his success which is
there are domains in which you can do a
whole lot better than experts cuz
experts do a whole lot of dumb things so
then that's my first that's that's
really first why is nate silver so good
we've got an answer hopefully second
question is nate silver any good okay
who here thinks nate silver is a
fantastic election forecaster
okay
why do you say that have any of you
actually gone through and put together a
spreadsheet looking at Nate's
projections and looked at the accuracy
of them and these more important
question many people say our will Nate
got 50 out of 50 in the last election
that's really impressive you know with
no math no time and no spreadsheets if
you simply said whoever won each state
last election will win it next time you
would have gotten 48 out of 50 so Nate
spent hundreds of hours for two extra
states the important question is not is
made any good it's is he better than the
alternative and trying to figure that
out it's really hard and in order to do
that what we're gonna need is lots of
races where we can compare Nate to an
alternative so if if we want to figure
out with an eight looks let's assume
that say Nate gets 80 percent of his
calls right in close races and each
election cycle has maybe five close
races because most of them are really
easy to predict right if you want to
figure out where the Nate is better than
the coin flip you're going to need three
election cycles to figure out whether
he's better than just dumb luck and he's
only been doing this for two and a half
cycles if you wanted to set a somewhat
higher bar and say Nate's really smart
he gets 80% of these races right and
Wolfers is a bit smart he gets 70% right
you'd need 90 close races to figure out
whether he whether he was beating me
just by do luck okay we get five close
races every four years that means we
need 18 election cycles or 72 years
before you can tell me where the Nate is
better at predicting elections than I am
so round about the year 2100 is when we
should be willing to crown Nate the king
of forecasters so you know the question
here is is Nate silver and he could I
think the right answer is it's really
unknowable so then can we do better so
one of the things I've done a lot of
work on is looking at prediction markets
this is just the idea that um you can
ask someone to bet will the Democrats
win the next presidential election right
now the Democrats are trading it around
a contractor pays a dollar if they win
the next elections trading it around 55
cents so you might infer from that the
Democrats are about a 55% chance to
when now I should also be the first to
admit Democrat that Democrats have their
flaws no I meant to say prediction
markets have their flaws so do Democrats
and we see some pathologies and
prediction markets sometimes they're a
little bit too willing to bet that along
shots actually going to win and so my
general advice to people who track
prediction markets is anytime the price
goes below ten percent or above 90%
ignore it because there's not much
information content there anytime the
markets too thin you should ignore it
and sometimes you want to take account
of this favorite long shot bias I had a
graduate student in 2008 who collected
friction market data and he also
collected nights he also collected
nights forecasts day by day
David Rothschilds his name and for the
2008 election he told me that his the
prediction markets actually the night
over many different time horizons
David hasn't yet done the update for
2012 maybe you've had a look at at night
you may well have had to come back this
time but um it does seem that certainly
prediction markets appear to do very
well this election cycle I'm let me now
get to the fourth thing which is what is
the future polling here's the thing I'm
most excited about Nate's models are
only as good as the inputs he feeds into
them the inputs he feeds into them are
standard election polls well you go out
and you ask someone who do you intend to
vote for when pollsters do that I think
they're treating polling respondents
with very little respect think about how
much information you know about the
election you know who you're thinking
about voting for you know the likelihood
you'll vote you know who your spouse is
likely to vote for you may have spoken
to your in-laws you may have been around
the water cooler recently you may have
seen how many yard signs are out in your
neighborhood you know a whole lot of
stuff about the forthcoming election
what a pollster asks is only one small
part of that information set who do you
intend to vote for instead they could
try an extract a richer information set
from you they could ask you instead who
do you think will win and in fact that a
very very little-known fact is they've
been doing that ever since the 1930s and
it turns out if you would put together a
this is joint work with David Ross tribe
we've put together a a database of polls
where they ask both who do you think
will win and who you intend to vote for
and if you use the standard question
that pollsters rely on and indeed that
Nate relies on out of the 345 races we
have you would have gotten 69 percent of
them right if instead you relied on this
completely different question who do you
think will win thereby hopefully
harnessing some of the wisdom of crowds
you would have got an 81 percent of
these races right and we think what's
going on is when we ask you who do you
think will win you're giving us some of
the information from your broader social
network in fact our rough guess it's as
as if I'm treating each person i poll as
a pollster themselves and each of them
has taken a poll of ten more of their
other friends now this is actually
really interesting for the future
polling the worst possible thing for pop
the worst thing that's happening to
polling right now is people are stopping
people just aren't responding anymore
and it's become incredibly difficult to
get representative samples of the US
population but if you ask people not who
do you think who do you intend to vote
probably you ask them who they think
will win maybe it's not such a bad thing
if you get unrepresentative samples
because even if you asked all
Republicans who they think will win
Republicans are a little bit too likely
I think Republicans can win but we can
correct for that but they're still
giving us a whole lot of information
about their social networks which may
themselves be quite unbiased and so this
may actually be way of coming up with
useful projections even when surveys
turn out to be incredibly biased now is
this a technology that works I think at
this point you know what invite you to
make one of two choices either you say
we can't figure out whether this is a
better technology because you need a
whole lot of data or you can say well
let's test them and see how they did in
the 2012 election so what this method
allows me to do and allowed me to do and
I published this in the New York Times
just prior to the 2012 election my
forecast I was totally embarrassed by
the way I looked at it throughout 2012
everyone always thought Obama would win
it was never going to be close if you
looked at my question as opposed to the
survey standard survey question but by
such a margin that you would have that I
was forced to predict that Obama would
win the election by five percentage
points when the computer spent that
number out as I got I mean done
this is going to be an embarrassing
forecast I'm gonna turn it sit there's
no way he wins by this much and just by
way of comparison Nate said he'd win by
two and a half
Simon Jackman upholster calm said one
point six and Sam Wang from the
Princeton election consortium two point
three on election night they it looked
like the number was bang on what Nate
said it actually turns out over the next
two months they got around to counting
all the votes and people in New York and
California vote a lot as do New Jersey
post hurricane sandy and Obama won the
election by four and a quarter so in
fact this method turned out in 2012 to
be the closest of all of them so you
know let me conclude where to next we
have better forecasting methods than
most prognosticators years and nights
shown that is a great example of that
and I think the most interesting and
exciting thing for you and certainly
this is what it's all my students is
what are the next domain in which there
are huge gains what's the field in which
you can go out and be the next Nate
Silver so I written a newspaper that
Nate thought economics made me was one
of them and I wanted to a distinction
there's two types of forecasting
economics there's forecasting what will
be the non-farm payrolls number next
next next Friday
like what's literally going to happen at
the end of the week and there we have
hundreds of market economists with very
strong incentives to get it exactly
right and I think that's an incredibly
difficult thing to do better on there's
a different thing which is forecasting
the economy which is where's the US
economy going to be one year out two
years out and this is actually what's
important and it turns out our state of
the art models dynamic stochastic
general equilibrium models that we teach
our PhD students barely do a better job
just a smidge better than just saying
whatever happened last year is going to
happen next year and so it does seem
that there's rayul there is the
possibility we could do a lot better in
economics the one that I'm most
optimistic about is human resources so
my sister in Australia works in human
resources and I asked once how do you do
your job you said Justin the candidates
just walk in and I just look at him and
I know
and I said how do you know if you were
right
I just know and there's never been a
single case she works at a leading HR
consultancy or did at the time there's
never been a single case when they went
back and assist with her judgments were
accurate and if you think about this
this is actually exactly the Moneyball
story Moneyball is an HR story right and
Nate actually made important
contributions to that but I think the
same thing exists much more broadly in
just about any of the tall buildings we
see across the skyline beyond that I
think another domain that's very
important Pharmaceuticals yeah yeah
which pharmaceutical companies
developing thousands of compounds
they've got great scientists doing that
but the firm actually really needs to
decide which of these compounds is more
likely to work out that's a forecasting
problem what they do at the moment is
they get their marketing people in a
scientist in a room and they yell at
each other but this is a huge multi
billion dollar decision that doesn't
have a lot of science and of course one
can't help but look at the mess in Iraq
and think the international relations is
not another case where we could have
done a bit better job with with more
formal forecasting techniques let me
stop there Thanks just like in the long
run I would expect that if markets are
efficient and they can look at British
markets are efficient they can look at
the 538 forecast and incorporate that
along with anything else I'm not I don't
know if I literally read the conclusion
of the paper about the Oh eight results
because if you'da bias in trade I think
there's a type of point but if you D by
us in Tribune you account for the
favorite longshot bias then I think it
did better but maybe not otherwise but
do you know what the biases are in
advance is it is a trickier question so
for example I think in general elections
in many other contexts you see the
prediction markets have a a longshot
bias okay a who you know say Walter
Mondale
in 1984 you know might have been trading
at 5 or 10% on on entry
if there were one back then when his
chance was probably 0.005% or something
like that instead in the Republican
primaries that you actually almost saw
the the reverse issue where you had
candidates who were not given enough
chance to have an upset so I think Rick
Santorum for example on the day before
the Colorado caucus was given only a
three percent chance of winning the
caucus which he did part of it is that
it's hard to say you have a kami who's
up by five points in the polls with with
the week to go how likely is he to win
you know your intuition for that problem
is not necessarily all that helpful and
it matters a lot whether you're in the
country sort of primary or a general
election so kinda ahead by five percent
in the polling average and say a typical
Senate race with week to go in the
campaign in November general election
might have a 95 percent chance of
winning mechanic the presidential
primary because the other gain is much
more unstable the polls are much less
accurate might have say a 70 percent
chance of winning instead I think maybe
in trade is not you don't have enough
sophisticated traders there to make
those points taken which are fairly
clear if you'd be in the exam and the
historical evidence but but might not
come across intuitively as much so I
mean but you know really I agree with
with about 99% of what Justin is saying
where really the fact that 538 was
celebrated somewhat just kind of tells
you how bad the competition is for the
most part especially in politics where
people have I think very perverse
incentives where ideology ideology
really gets in the way a lot of time
we've had a small and fairly insular
journalism industry that only now is
kind of changing I think very much at
all so it really helps to pick fields
where where everyone else is making a
lot of mistakes and you can look like a
genius just by being kind of average or
you know dude give a B+ forecast and
look like a very smart guy instead so
you know my advice to you is go identify
some industries and this way few people
are really dumb and then and then the
average and you'll do really well for
yourself
okay Phil well I'm the dinosaur
I'm the dinosaur on the panel here and
I've been I've been running political
forecasting tournaments for a long time
III got initially got into the business
in the early 1980s as the Soviet Union
was approaching a critical transition
point with Gorbachev and liberals and
conservatives and pundits had very
different opinions about different
different views of where the Soviet
Union was heading and for different
reasons
the Liberals were claiming for example
that the Reagan defense build-up was
driving the Soviet Union toward a neo
Stalinist retrench meant that was a
common liberal prediction at the time
and conservatives were claiming that the
Soviet Union had perfected the art of
totalitarian cloning and that they would
be just an endless succession of gray
suit equally drab general party
secretaries into the indefinite future
then along came Gorbachev and
increasingly dramatic liberalisation
8687 and the interesting thing was that
I observed back then was that nobody
felt much of a need to change their
minds
the Liberals felt that well yes of
course the Soviets are doing this
because the economy's falling apart is
happening despite not because of Reagan
and the Conservatives are saying well
you know I guess they didn't have they
hadn't perfected that they are the
toilet area loaning out the Soviet the
Soviet Union they blinked Reagan pushed
them and they blinked so each side you
know saw no need really to change its
fundamental assessment of the situation
and this post hoc ergo propter hoc
propter hoc sort of reasoning led me to
start running larger forecasting
tournaments in 1988 1992 in which we
asked lots of political experts lots of
questions about countries around the
world sometimes the involved election
sometimes involved economic growth
sometimes they involved Wars and whatnot
and as Justin suggests the performance
was not very strong
the experts had a hard time no they did
a little bit better than the dart
throwing chimpanzee they did not most of
them did not do better than simple
extrapolation algorithms you know
predicting essentially the status quo
which is Justin just pointed out is it's
a rather hard benchmark to beat
sometimes in American elections as well
so that was that was the work that led
up to the book on expert political
judgment how good is it how can we know
and it's often identified with a rather
rather pessimistic assessment of the
quality of political judgment or
recently I've become involved in a
project under the auspices of the
Intelligence Advanced Research Projects
Agency in which the goal is less to
curse the darkness and more to light
candles it's it's an it's an effort to
see how good political forecasting can
become and here I think Nate and Justin
really do represent the future when
you're in this kind when you're in this
kind of a competitive tournament with
with other university teams and you're
trying to minimize the gaps between
probability and reality year after year
you're pretty much forced to be very
eclectic and opportunistic engineer in
the in the methods you use so we were
very very eclectic and opportunistic
about how the individual differences
among forecasters that we that we study
and how we weight those we're very
eclectic and opportunistic about the
training materials we developed we're
very eclectic and opportunistic about
where the prediction markets and and the
pros and cons and having people engage
in competitive second-guessing of each
other's predictions and prediction
markets as opposed to more collaborative
teamwork so we're replacing our bets on
many different things and there's many
different elicitation methods many
different aggregation methods many
different training methods and we're
doing the best we can to minimize the
gaps between probability and reality and
I would just say that when you look at
the very best forecasters in they are
for tournament they have a rather Nate
silver ish cognitive style they are
there they're they're very methodical
they're they're they're quite modest and
they they try to identify the most
plausible base rates they try to
identify
Bayesian diagnostic signposts they
gradually update sometimes they move
they move faster it's something to move
slow or the function of the news but
they they they they they they're pretty
good and they they they seem to be
learning over time to become better
they're becoming increasingly well
calibrated so when I went on this panel
here at Nate and Justin really do
represent I think the future of
political forecasting they're our best
forecasters look a lot like whether they
aspire to be like Nate because Nate
Nate's kind of a cognitive role model
for them and the one of the very best
experimental methods we have for
generating forecasts it's not the best
and I could explain for various
technical reasons why that may be the
case
our prediction market so prediction
markets are a powerful way of bringing
out the best from the best forecasters
so what we have here are you know to
compliment I see essentially
complimentary approaches we're drawing
on both in various ways in the art for
forecasting tournament and it it works I
think when you approach political
forecasting it pays not to have strong
priors it pays to be eclectic and
opportunistic and follow up on leads
whenever wherever they may arise and
that's what we're doing as we move into
the third year of the eye out for
forecasting tournament and if anybody's
interested in participating and seeing
how well they can do is it signing
subjective probabilities to a wide range
of political geopolitical events there's
a website www.prophecyinthenews.com with
and then we'll so so I guess one thing
up you know I've been thinking about
recently has been preparing for this
discussion is one thing that seems
intriguing is to what extent people be
it voters or be political parties or
might respond to the predictions
either you or other pollsters or
predictors of other kinds make so once
sort of this really enters into the
public consciousness that these
predictions can be reasonably accurate
you might think that this affects how
voters actually behaved so there's lots
of evidence that many voters vote they
have a preference to vote for winners
for instance or you might think that
this affects just turnout decisions if
you gather that your favorite candidate
is extremely likely to win in some state
why bother going to vote for him and I
was just wondering whether you've sort
of have views about how the fact that
these predictions do become more
accurate might end up influencing
people's behavior you might think it of
influences party's behavior about how
they campaign and then sort of what that
does actually to the accuracy of the
predictions themselves so I guess I'd
say kind of thinking about this more
broadly I think media coverage can
influence voting decisions and maybe
polling is a subset of media coverage
and what I do is a subset of that
potentially but you do see cases
especially when voters have some reason
to behave tactically so in the Iowa
caucus for example a week before the
caucus you had you know Mitt Romney had
his 20% Ron Paul had his 20% and then
you had Rick Perry and Michele Bachmann
and Rick Santorum all tied at about 10
percent and they were very very similar
candidates most Michele Bachmann fans
would prefer Rick Perry or Santorum to
Romney or or Ron Paul so you would think
voters have it would have an incentive
to get behind one of these conservative
kind of Tea Party candidates instead so
they could win the Iowa caucus and
remain viable in the race but there's
kind of no trigger and then CNN came up
with a poll which had like a small
sample size like a few hundred people
that had Santorum searching all of a
sudden from 10% to 16% now the margin of
error is is quite high when you have 300
people in your poll or so but low and
behold I wrote about this poll in a lot
of media other media outlets word about
this poll and so what was probably an
outlying poll became
actual momentum the Des Moines Register
which takes a larger sample saw is
probably a better poll in CNN also found
Santorum increases for 10 percent to 15
percent but they actually found that
when they looked at the numbers day by
day it was tied apparently to the
release of the CNN poll where he jumped
from 10 percent to 20 percent
the morning after this the spate of
favorable coverage as a result of people
having this this cue to behave
tactically instead so I guess I do worry
a little bit I mean if you do have
people who are influenced by your
prediction it could potentially
undermine your model you'd rather kind
of keep off the the real world kind of
hermetically sealed and perform your
experiment on it and then not have to
worry about people reacting to it but
but it does worry me a bit I think it's
the least likely to be concerned in a
general election for the presidency
versus primaries in cases say we're part
of trying to allocate resources where I
know if we have for example an obscure
US House candidates say Democrat in
Colorado worse do we say although she
only has a three percent chance of
winning you know I might get angry
emails from her chief of staff because
because that means that the Democratic
campaign committees will donate to some
other candidate instead potentially so
that might actually make them proud of
the the predictions of it
self-fulfilling in a sense so that that
can be problematic I'd say but but I
think that's true with any kind of
campaign coverage so it's not unique to
this kind of thing doesn't you want to
chime in about sort of the effects of
prediction markets and these things or
like I thought Nate gave a splendid
answer um there's certainly perception
or a belief that I my reading of the
evidence and here I would defer to
others is that how voters respond to
information about how they can and it's
doing is not quite as obvious as we
economists think it should be so if your
candidate is doing exceptionally well it
turns out people like to turn out to
celebrate the winner rather than stay
home and look after their kids the one
thing I do know is that there have been
historically they used to be very large
prediction markets in 1920s and 1930s in
the u.s. literally on the curb at Wall
Street people betting millions of
dollars and Tammany Hall actually had a
campaign chest to go and bet in the
markets so that they would affect the
coverage of the election so what does
that tell us it doesn't tell us that
prediction markets shape election
outcomes it tells us Tammany Hall
believes prediction markets shape
election outcomes it's less clear to me
that they actually do yet of course the
amount of scrutiny that forecasts get
seems to me to be getting ever higher
than so that you know everything could
change
so did you say say that and Nate Nate
really went through the crucible in the
EEM a lot of Republicans came to the
conclusion that he was essentially
working for the Democratic Party and
trying to create a self-fulfilling
prophecy of a rock Romney Romney defeat
in the process he revealed a lot of
statistical illiteracy in the punditry
but it is it is a difficult position to
be in when you're making predictions
like that and it it's not widely
appreciated how much more confidence you
can become when you bite when you
aggregate many imperfect measures it's
somewhat counterintuitive for people so
I guess another another question I was
wondering about is sort of where you see
aside from using polls as information
using prediction markets to in order to
make predictions it's sort of odd there
are other resources so they're
interesting studies about social media
for instance so there was a study in
Germany I think it was that that was
talking about using Twitter messages in
order to be able to make that just a
volume of Twitter messages in order to
be able to make alcohol predictions and
I was you know lucky to comment on just
weather where you see this coin I mean
one problem is that if this stuff has
only been collected recently then it's
hard to it's hard to test it to put it
in them are with other things and see
how well it might do you know there some
just said Twitter on the one hand it for
example seemed to indicate that
Democrats would get a bigger bump out of
their convention than the GOP did
because they got much more favorable
sentiment and the sample of Twitter
users is is a is a biased sample by a
statistical sense we have a lot more
liberals than conservatives you have a
lot of very high information voters so I
tend to be I tend to be a little bit
skeptical I also you know keep in mind
that with within certain boundaries
polling is is pretty decent late in the
campaign and that if you look at polling
plus some notion of economic conditions
you can do you can
fairly well so so the value of adding
additional information at the March and
it's not necessarily easy to clear that
bar versus a feel of where you're
totally and completely lost it might be
more useful for example in in the
primaries which where the polling is is
not as accurate where it's hard to find
other measures that reliably give you
predictive success then that might tell
you more but I think in in general
elections I think it's it's it remains
to be seen how much value would add on
the other hand by the way Internet
polling where what Google would actually
kind of randomly poke people if they're
going to some site they had a paywall
and say hey instead of instead of having
to pay for this pay while while you take
a poll instead well the Google poll that
did really well and other polls that
were conducted online actually did
better than traditional telephone polls
this year so I think that that's kind of
more likely to be the the game-changer
so let me add just two things to that so
again I agree with name when people talk
about a list new social media data and
they talk about big data they're
confusing big data and small data at the
end of it all if I say 57% of people in
2012 were tweeting in a pro-democratic
way that's one observation even if there
were 10 million people tweet and going
into that and you've got one observation
which you then have to calibrate which
is to say you need to take account of
the bias that Nate was just talking
about which is how damn liberal our
Twitter users anyway by the time you've
done the calibration you've got no
degrees of freedom left over and you can
do literally nothing with it and by next
election cycle 2016 you say well now
I'll have two observations surely you
can do something with two observations
well you could if you're willing to
assume that the population using Twitter
in 2016 is similar to that using it in
2012 which is surely a terrible
assumption the second observation I want
to make is I think this actually does
come back to navin's previous question
which is yes you know how to forecasts
end up becoming self-fulfilling I think
social media actually has a real
possibility of doing that Brendon 9 and
he's a wonderful young political
scientist at Dartmouth who's become the
self-appointed political science cop who
goes out knee yells journalists whenever
they're committing sin
and to his eye one of the great sins is
they all sit on Twitter talking to each
other during the debate about how the
debates going and within 12 minutes the
debates starting you can already write
tomorrow's headlines it because it's so
I don't have data to back this up but if
you actually just you know beyond the
story but you watch the story and
Brendan's viewers if you want to be a
serious journalist you should turn
social media off actually watch the
debate that's happening and then the
next morning's headlines will at least
be a sampling of 100 journalists around
the country 100 independent-samples is a
whole lot better reading than one sample
from a hundred of them sitting in a room
talking to each other over Twitter yeah
people don't really what people don't
know that so I got to go to a debate in
New Hampshire when the interminable GOP
primary debates this year right but I
get to go to a debate so I thought I'll
go in the debate hall and kind of over
here with the with the common folk are
saying right and instead you're like
literally put in a giant gymnasium with
every other member of the political
press corps right and everyone's talking
out loud and looking at each other over
each other's shoulders and kind of
tweeting in unison so I do think the
fact that you've had both in the
primaries and the general elections this
year the debates were where more had
more impact on the polls than they have
in the past I do think you have a lot of
groupthink there I mean if you want to
study media bias just as general
proposition and study the reaction to
two debates like pretty much every form
of media biases is present in the way
that the debates are covered where for
example in the after the third debate
you had people who were seconding by the
people saying well well you know I think
it was a tie so Romney wins right you
know it was like literally that explicit
so but anyway it's no surprise that
groupthink occurs and you literally have
an environment to cultivate it and have
everyone thinking together kind of in a
room together okay let's let's perhaps
open it up so maybe what what we could
do is I have people raise hands and then
walk over the mic over there and
and uh I'll just I'll try to point
accurately and if you can walk over to
the mic and ask a question that would be
great
sir and perhaps you could just introduce
yourself for a second just to tell us
what your affiliation is my name is Paul
Burke I'm Columbia graduate so among all
the pulses that we see quoted in the
papers or even on TV talk shows there
are some people that are identified as
democratic pollsters or Republican
pollsters I've never quite first of all
the first question is what does that
really even mean the second question or
relate to that is is there a different
incentive to be right I mean I'm
thinking if I'm running a media for CNN
or something like that I don't really
care so much of my but my pulse is
ultimately correct but if I'm learning
if somebody's campaign then I want that
poster to be giving me accurate
information so is there a difference in
terms of accuracy and the kinds of
information and or maybe that I give her
does that poster give a different kind
of information answer when he's on TV
than when he's talking to the person
that's been you know writing the checks
well so I so one way to define a
democratic pollster or compulsory is one
that actually does work for campaigns
and you have some polling firms that
that do both they'll have some polls
Commission on behalf of campaigns and
some of they do privately but aren't
they also you know that's that's it yeah
that assumption that all people care
about the truth does not go very far I
don't think I mean it's so obvious in a
lot of ways right but but we really are
operating kind of a a post truth
environment in politics a lot of time or
maybe it's nothing new but you know I
you know politics is the art of kind of
manipulating public opinion in some
respects and shading the truth and so it
the ethics are very different I mean
believe me their person said as an
academia as well I'm sure but politics
is really toxic that way in a lot of
respects but one problem too is that
journalists have a lot of incentive to
put put a lot of weight on proprietary
information whether or not it's reliable
so when you get the internal polls
released by a campaign for example
they're treated as being very prophetic
when
fact you can look at them and they are
almost always biased in the direction of
the candidate who who puts out the polls
by an average of about six points in
fact on average just way off the mark if
you take out if you remove that bias can
actually tell you something some of the
time but not always but when you get
that inside information and you're
getting it because someone's trying to
trying to spin right or because their
themselves have become a little bit
detached from from reality I think you
know it's hard to in in organizations
it's hard to be the bearer of bad news
sometimes and you have campaigns like
the Romney campaign where the pollster
is is not just an internal pulse but
also a public spokesperson for the
campaign those are two very different
and somewhat opposite roles I think I
think campaigns that kind of keep their
pollsters more isolated from one another
one thing the Obama campaign did in 2008
for example they had multiple different
pollsters we had disagreements you could
you could hash this out and maybe have a
healthier debate about that so so yes
I'm sorry kind of rambling here but you
know the first point is that we hear
about internal polls released by a
campaign that's usually that's usually a
scoop it's not really worth anything
it's for the most part and and
number two that campaigns could
certainly benefit from encouraging their
their pollsters to have better
incentives but it's it's hard to do in
practice Phil I I certainly agree with
Nate that truth often runs a four second
or third to entertainment value and
reinforcement of prejudices in
consumption of political advice and
punditry
but I think it probably is a price that
you do that that but in House Republican
or democratic pollsters would pay if
they prove to be systematically wrong so
these I don't know if it's true but I've
heard it said that rotten Romney
actually thought he was going to win I
think you know that is true though the
pollsters who led him to think that all
right aren't they going to pay some kind
of a credibility price next time around
there's definitely been a lot of talk in
the GOP about how to reform their
polling operations and I think I think
they are aware of it for the most part
when I talk to and I try and avoid
having too much contact with the
campaigns but I did talk to them at the
convention of the GP Ken
and at that point it seemed like the
Romney polling team saw it more or less
as the public polls did which at that
point had Romney narrowly behind but you
had a lot of time in the campaign still
you had a lot of uncertainty about what
might happen still toward the end of a
campaign is when the polls become much
more reliable and so that's when you
might have the problems with with denial
right where if you're down by if you're
down by two points in September it means
well let's shift our message a bit and
we can win what's the big deal if you're
down by two points on election eve you
probably gonna lose that election ninety
percent of time and it's too late to do
anything about it and so it might be
harder to tell to deliver that news to
the candidate instead but I'm sure
Romney thought he was he was I don't
know actually you know Romney certainly
said he was gonna win but of course what
a county has to say when he's asked by
by the press what you really think I
think that's probably I think it's
probably false I mean one thing it's
funny about the press coverage of the
campaign says a politician who has a
reputation for fibbing a lot right for
some reason the press always believes
the most recent thing that he said right
so Romney recently said oh the whole 47%
comments you know that wasn't the real
me
right it's like why should we believe
that now you know now of course it's one
look like a look like a bad guy but but
it's not always clear what the
campaign's really think I think you know
you people who are trained to to spin
the information in a way that that
presents it favorably and I think it's
it's hard to do that for a living and
not and not buy into some of the
yourself maybe for very good
but but most people I think if they're
in that paradigm we're gonna become
detached from from kind of the objective
reality
you know since the economist failed to
predict the recession 2007 nine are they
trying to resuscitate their their image
of by going into this political area or
as you say mr. Hobart you know are you
going to co-op the methods of political
science like Bob Shapiro's and develop
your databases and then say it's you
know economic prediction doesn't so
here's a secret no one in academia cares
about forecasting it's actually
completely accurate statement I can say
that as a practicing macro economist I
go to dozens of macroeconomics
conferences each year I see
incredibly complex and elegant models
with Greek letters I've never seen
before but almost never does anyone say
here is the fit of this model to the
things you care about and compare it to
what actually happens and in fact I this
very briefly before the current fad
within modern macroeconomics is an
incredibly complex form of mathematical
model called a dynamic stochastic
general equilibrium model which you're
if you're a mathematician you'll find
incredibly elegant and it takes many of
them take a high-tech computer three or
four days to solve yet there's only been
two serious analyses of the ability of
these things to predict the future and
it's dreadful and you know that there's
no market for doing that kind of
research and then the same is equally
true by the way in political science
which is you know when I tell my friends
and I'm doing stuff on predicting
elections they're like oh that's like
political science right truth is is
maybe three or four political scientists
I can have a serious conversation with
about predicting elections Bob Eric's is
here he's one of them but there's not
really you know and there's a few people
who understand that if they get in this
game they can get their name in the
newspaper every four years but it's not
really a serious part of the enterprise
and if it were a serious part of the
enterprise
by the way we wouldn't spend our time on
predicting elections it's not actually
socially important what would be more
socially important we'd be able to
predict you know what's going on with
the regulatory process what legislation
will pass things like that who wins or
who loses it's it's great water cooler
talk but I don't think it's actually
that important this actually part of the
reason Nate can be so successful those
of us in the Academy have no interest
whatsoever in prediction which means a
smart outsider can come in and do it
better than the rest of us and then I
think by the way some part of this is a
floor of the Academy which is as a
result people think a smart guy like
Nate can be better than modern political
science than they think modern political
science may not be up to much
well they're off doing something else
but it's definitely bad for the
reputation in the field just as missing
a major financial crisis was probably at
the margin bad for the reputation of
economists why do you think it is that
forecasting is is not held in high
esteem in either academic economics or
political science that's a great
question I mean you you probably you're
in a discipline where it's taken
somewhat more seriously well that's
different
it's the study of expert judgment is
different from actually forecasting yeah
but go ahead do you have any thoughts
about why that was a preamble leading up
to me running out of woods cuz I don't
have a clue one possibility is that
academic political scientists and
economists don't see the outcomes as
being theory relevant they think that
the actual
outcomes that do occur are gone or
occurring for many occurring as a result
of factors over which they have no
control there are that are often
exogenous and that are often fluky so
they see the outcomes as having low
diagnostician v's to be the theories
they care about wait well but you know
so I sometimes get this I mean actually
as Justin said earlier you know our
models take into account a lot of the
political science research where you
know for example there are models that
have an
genomic component as as ours does as
well as a choline component but what you
do is actually use just like we use a
polling consensus we use a consensus of
economic indicators which helps you
quite a bit there's one model for
example that that is designed based on
disposable income per capita disposable
income and that stat has been reliable
the past was kind of an outlier relative
to other economic numbers
this past cycle it was really bad
whereas the rest were just kind of
pretty bad and some models based on that
variable did quite poorly where where
those that use some kind of economic
index as mine did or I think actually is
Bob Erickson's does as well they tended
to do pretty well instead but you know I
mean why do i why do you academics
resist well I guess if I was gonna make
first is that you know if you say well
this model is not grounded in theory
it's just kind of you're selling fun and
making a forecast you know my view is a
theory isn't worth very much if it
doesn't make good predictions in the
long run of course there are reasons
that even you know that I face that
coming stakes you don't want to sit
credibility on one short-term outcome
when you can't really test whether it
makes predictions in the long run or not
based on say one election or something
but it's a way to avoid accountability I
think in a lot of respects you know a
lot of the theory I mean the disturbing
thing to me is that in cases where we
have been able to look at a lot of data
and see how well experts are doing
overall when it comes to forecasting the
result with some exceptions is generally
not very good right and that's the stuff
that we can actually test and usually
usually testability is a good criteria
for for science right so that means all
the theories which which aren't tested
might be even worse potentially so it's
a little disturbing I think well there
there's one factor you're missing here
which is so I have tenure I could come
up with a dumbest focus in the world I
could be I could miss every financial
crisis I could get every election wrong
and I still have a job if Knight does
that he gets fired so then it's a given
those incentives it's even more
surprising that I'm not making more
projections and Nate's not making less
there is another factor which is just
that forecasting economic issues in some
ways is much harder than forecasting
elections especially when you get up
close to the election right so that you
touched on this earlier I mean the the
predictions get more accurate as you get
closer to the event and I'm surprised
that neither of you commented on that
yes well I mean you know there's a lot
of noise and economic data and it's a
very basic thing where you know why is
it hard as just was saying to forecast
non-farm payrolls well there a lot of
reasons but one is that there's a big
sampling error right I think the
sampling error alone is like when
standard errors like 70,000 jobs per
month there's something and then so
you'll have reports where it's like the
numbers forecasted to be 130 K and it
comes in at 110 K it's like Oh gigantic
gigantic miss like really that's better
than we do 90% of time with every bounce
right but people don't communicate that
very well and so by the way so there's a
role here for for for reporters and kind
of the media as intermediaries between
academic science and between what
economists are saying and and what kind
of lay people are doing in and often
those messengers are poor messengers
where where you know I think I've gotten
like too much credit since the election
frankly I think I would have gotten too
much blame also if Romney had won
instead but but they aren't necessarily
communicating the science very well and
you have people who just kind of one
basic conclusion of the signal the noise
that the people who are the most
confident are often the worst
forecasters but they often make the best
kind of television guests instead and so
that can that can lead you even further
astray
we can understand why they so bad at it
imagine being a business reporter who
wrote the headline non-farm payrolls
either went up a bit a lot or not very
much which is the accurate headline well
in large and general with this I mean a
lot of time the the accurate headline is
nothing important happened today go
watch the Yankees game and have a beer
right you know in the campaign you might
have two or three really important
moments sir the course of campaign if
you have a major economic shift or a war
starts or maybe the first couple of
debates but for the most part nothing
which is changing from from day to day
but you always have to fill colleges
instead so you really put an emphasis on
on the noise so to speak I I'm an
undergraduate in Columbia College
studying political science and
statistics and this past year I worked
for two different democratic polling
firms one of which ride relied
exclusively on online cooling and the
other one exclusively on landline phone
polling how do your models account for
the variety in the medium of polling and
as technology moves forward how do you
think holsters are going to be able to
best reach voters so so I'll give you
the kind of literal answer for how the
538 model does it which as Justin said
if you if you d bias the polls meaning
understand that Rasmussen polls are
Republican leaning or PPP are democratic
leaning and that removes some of the
noise but the question is what UD bias
it to and I don't just use a straight
average of all polling firm what I used
as an average of polling firms that use
traditional telephone polling and call
and call cell phones right you know
that's the kind of Prior I'm introducing
but if you have a poll amount where you
don't call cell phones and you're only
reaching you know roughly 6% of the
population then that's you know it's
arguably not even a scientifical to
begin with it becomes more almost like
good if you call random landlines and
you get like a lot of 65 year-old women
answering the phone but literally you'll
have you know seventy percent of the
sample sometimes if you call random
digit dial landline phones will be from
senior citizens right now because people
under the age of 50 by and large don't
pick up the phone anymore under many
circumstances they pick up their cell
phones instead they assume it's a
telemarketer and so that's a huge that's
a huge issue so you know again a lot of
this pretty basic that the more you
actually make an effort to go out and
survey everyone and not just people that
are easiest to reach the better off
you'll do you know we have now had had
landline penetration has fallen beneath
internet penetration that will keep
going up so I mean I think you're I'm
just gonna have more roll for for
internet polls I mean what I hope you'll
have Frank these I hope you'll still
have some some expensive polling done by
the networks that uses
cause landlines and cell phones and
tries to get as many people as they can
and then you have internet people
something like that you get rid of these
in between Robo poles where you're
taking just a landline sample in a
really quick and dirty way those poles
have not had a couple of have not been
very good by and large in 2012 and 2010
and they might get squeezed out I think
so I think there is a huge problem with
getting representative samples right now
and say you know you're right said the
non cell phone universe clearly not
representative the online-only universe
clearly not representative even those
who try and bridge it you know Gallup
does both cell phone and and landline
what no one tells you and this is the
truly dirty secret of polling is what's
going on with response rates so in the
80s were up around 40% now it's down
around 8 or 9% so people who respond to
polls are true weirdos that a one in 12
who wants to for free talk to a pollster
rather than getting on with their lives
and they're the ones who are informing
so much of our political discourse so I
have a prediction which is some time
this is still falling my prediction is
there will be an election cycle in which
we get a huge shock when we finally
learn that you know the final 5% of left
are just total weirdos and they're
completely different to the 9 percent
that we calibrated our models on from
now the careful thing I did with my
forecast here is you know the old dictum
always say what or when never both so
I'll never be wrong because it'll happen
one day but you know even when Nate's
really confident the day before his
forecast I was worried what if this year
went down to 7% and 7% a wildly
unrepresentative relative to the 12%
that calibrated his models and we've got
no idea on that one one way the surveys
can go wrong is indeed this issue of
representativeness and it is a looming
crisis as Justin suggests another way it
could go wrong and it's more
theoretically interesting maybe from a
social science point of view is if
self-reported data are misleading
so I don't know quite what you guys
think about the Bradley effect but there
were certainly were some social
psychologists who suspected that Obama
would win less of the vote partly
because of social desirability reasons
people didn't want to say they were not
going to vote for an african-american
candidate but also partly because of
unconscious biases to which people
wouldn't have introspective access now
now that the Bradley effect is
controversial in political science and
I'm not sure what the latest with the
latest views on it are do you have an
opinion about it couldn't princess I
think I think the research had had shown
that it had dissipated that this
template be true in the 1970s and 1980s
if you had an african-american candidate
he would tend to underperform his polls
that hadn't been is true recently as
much one reason to think it wouldn't
have been true in advance of the 2008
general election with because it hadn't
really been true in the primaries by and
large where you had Annette you'd had
Hillary beat her polls in some states
and Obama beat his in some states but
you hadn't really had any bias overall
against Obama so so at this point I
think we're pretty sure that that Obama
won't underperform his polls maybe maybe
a different african-american candidate
would but but if you see it for example
in in some polls on on gay marriage
where where gay marriage ballot
initiatives tend to do a little worse
the Pro same-sex marriage side than the
polls just in advance I think part
what's happening is if you have opinions
shifting very rapidly you might have a
lot of soft support so maybe in the 70s
when people were for the first time
consider voting for an african-american
mayor or something or or senator or
governor you know they kind of would say
yeah I'll do it but they weren't clearly
comfortable with it and and you might
have the same effect now with with gay
marriage instead where people are like
well you know I don't want up in the
gays but then you get in the polling
place then you behave a little bit
differently so I think it might be a
sign of when you're rapidly moving
toward greater tolerance or greater
equality and then once it becomes more
commonplace what's Obama's been in your
living room certainly for for eight
years then it dissipates so
but this brings me to a follow-up
question which is to what extent art is
your strategy reducible to an algorithm
and to what extent are you engaging in
subjective tweaks based on well might
you think it's a hunch about the Bradley
effect your the hunch about this here's
a hunch about that we caught we call our
subjective tweaks our Bayesian priors
that's the no no you absolutely have to
make a lot of judgment calls where you
know there are so kind of before 538 for
the last six or seven election cycles
there have been a lot of models that are
published by political scientists that
use some combination of economic
variables polling based or attitudinal
variables right sometimes very well
syndicate incumbency or war or whatever
else and I think in the 2008 cycle there
were there were eight or ten of these
models that use like 23 different
variables between them right so you know
there are a lot of choice you have to
make about so for example you know I
think the principle is very strong that
over the long run that taking a
consensus of noisy data whether it's
polls or economic data will will win out
right so even if I had found that one
particular economic variable and if you
have literally 60,000 economic variables
now at the Federal Reserve's website of
course you would find several variables
that might be better the consensus but I
would still use the consensus index
number instead because I think it would
perform better over the long run so you
do have to make judgments like that and
hopefully they're informed by the kind
of broader literature about what what
works in forecasting it so there's an
interesting body of work in psychology
known as policy capturing in which
researchers try to create a statistical
model of the expert they try to create a
gist achill model that captures the
queue utilization strategy of the expert
so you could create it's just a
statistical model of a group of
radiologists and how they make judgments
and then you'd compare what's more
accurate is it the expert or the model
of the expert in a cross-validation
right so you could in principle do that
with Nate Silver - right you could have
Nate Silver and a model and we
against each other I think that'd be
very frightening there is a macro
economics literature that does that so
do you add judgment factors to the model
so most of these Wall Street guys have a
principled model then they are judgments
and my understanding of that literature
is that those judgments actually do
improve accuracy the psychologists more
skeptical the psychologists tend to find
that the models outperform the experts
from whom the models were derived so the
psychological literature is but I think
there have been a couple of exceptions
that but I think the preponderance of
the evidence is that the models actually
do better than the original experts
because the model tomorr consistent and
the experts get more distracted by
studio diagnostic use like you were
saying during elections about oh maybe
one or two but maybe you're really good
at zeroing in on the sub then under
truly diagnostic use and discounting
this the suits the HSU their diagnostic
ones but Momo Momo most experts do get
distracted in them and the models don't
get distracted by those things well yeah
I would say kind of a joe's question of
when should you count for for subjective
information and judgment calls of course
how you define subjective information is
itself tricky but you know that that
ought to be an empirical question and
you can have a different answer in
different fields I did a study of the
baseball forecasting program we had
called pakoda compared it to the lists
that were made by scouts and the scouts
actually their judgment actually did a
fair bit better about 20% better than
then my system alone did so that's a
case where we're hey the scouts are
adding or adding value kind of contra
money ball there are other cases where
we're maybe in psychology where that
isn't the case but that's why I say we
we need to collect data sets where we
actually can evaluate forecasters and
experts and see maybe there are some
heuristics kind of Maca used for when
judgment tends to help and when it
doesn't but we don't even have that many
case studies really to even even know in
a systematic way I don't think so let's
take a couple more questions
perhaps upfront I'm an undergraduate at
the University of Chicago and I had a
studying econ in math and I had a
follow-up question about the the econ
prediction issues that were brought up
so I guess the first part is so what do
you see as professor Wolfers and anyone
else who has opinion on this what do you
see is sort of the way forward here do
you think we need to come with a new
dynamic equilibrium model or do we need
to forget that whole approach and start
relying on some sort of prediction just
based off of trend lines in our
macroeconomic data do we need better
data collection tools and is that the
main thing and the second thing is sort
of how we question about how we try to
remove political biases from our
economic predictions and our economic
modelling in the sense that I think that
people's priors about economics are a
lot more strongly held than their priors
about say thorough Dyne thermodynamics
and so when you become an economist and
you take econ classes you know that
might not change your your views as much
as taking a physics class changes your
views about you know can convection so
how do we try to is there some
statistical way that we can try to
devious our economic predictions and D
by it let's try to remove the bias from
the way that we're constructing our
models to begin with
thank you great questions let me take
the second one first because it's easier
so you're worried you're very worried
about the role of ideology in economic
forecasting and here I think you need to
draw a sharp distinction between
economic forecasters the folks on Wall
Street versus editorial writers the
folks in the Wall Street Journal The
Wall Street Journal op-ed page will but
always be has always been a political
and politically contested place right
even worse it's not contested
and you know there's no a tip data deep
bias the guys on Wall Street I'm struck
by it you know the chief economist say
it goldman sachs yun hats yes actually
have no idea which way he votes all of
the market forecasters who are actually
doing the forecasting dara heck of a lot
like Nate
a little bit addressed but they're they
have a very very strong truth motivation
they're one the big bias they have two
big biases one they're overconfident
because it turns out the role of
economic forecasters on Wall Street is
not in fact to forecast the economy it's
to go to lunch with clients and be
eloquent and so effectively they are
sort of the paid entertainment and again
you can't get a lunch with clients and
so you know the economy could go up it
could go down the truth is we don't have
a clue
so they oversell their stories and the
other thing is they don't change their
mind often enough and I have research in
fact with ricardo reis on exactly this
point they will not change their story
more than once a year because if i say
oh it looks like the economy strung up
I mean week a new daddy came in maybe in
between now I look like I didn't have a
clue what the hell I was doing what in
fact what I was doing was you know
completely rational way responding to
data so they don't change their mind
enough your first question was much more
challenging which is how do we create an
economics that forecasts better I'm
probably not the right person to answer
but I will give you my one-minute spiel
on this I believe that the way we judge
academic economics and and macroeconomic
models is very much on the grounds of
elegance rot Bob Lucas won the Nobel
Prize for the rational expectations
hypothesis that led to two revolutions
one was it fundamentally changed how we
did macroeconomics and the second had
led to an empirical literature which
people tested rational expectations and
there is not been a single paper written
in that literature that found anything
other than it's false
so we have a we have a great taste for
elegance and I think what we need
instead is a truth motivation and here
I'm greatly inspired by behavioral
economists who it turns out despite what
Bob Lucas believes most of us don't
spend our days and nights dreaming about
inflation trying to calculate the
optimal inflation forecast most of us
are busy who have other things to do we
make decisions based on imperfect
information and often pretty bad
judgments and so with what we want to
desire is macro models that delivered
forecasts that were true they should be
based on foundations that are true and
so I think have to pay greater attention
to people's actual behavior rather than
their imagined behavior yes over in the
corner
hi I'm an undergraduate at Columbia
College certain clinical science our
system of course is a
first-past-the-post system I was
wondering if in the business of
forecasting and predictions if we'd also
looked at different kinds of electoral
systems would it be you know
parliamentary wispy our system or
alternative vote Instant Runoff system
and I guess most generally if there are
any methodological or you know findings
quirks that we notice that might be
different that kind of bucked
expectations and then more on top of
that weather forecasts are less relevant
for those kind of systems that suppose
that there might be less we need for
tactical voting and a lot of these
systems the you know for instance even
the UK which is also first-past-the-post
system the election season is much
shorter than the u.s. election system
and how forecasting might apply to these
other electoral systems and whether that
says something about our own that can't
be generalized to democracy engine you
know it definitely makes my job easier
when you have a two-way election that's
there are a lot of reasons why primaries
for example are much harder to forecast
than general elections but one reason is
that you have multiple candidates see do
necessarily have tactical behavior you
know we tried to kind of do a forecast
of the UK elections I think it was 2010
and our model got a case of Clegg mania
I think actually and didn't do that well
but when you have when you have shifts
there for example where if you're not
making good assumptions about what might
happen if if Liberal Democratic support
collapses where might it go and it
turned out that a lot of went back to
labour instead of - to the Tories so you
know that kind of thing where you have
to make more assumptions and and it
makes things a lot harder but you know I
think there are some constants my
understanding is that the the across a
wide variety of context and economic
performance matters and tends to help be
incumbent party when the economy is
doing well but yeah being able to have a
two-way election is is a lot simpler you
know in fact in art in our models that I
use we treat third party voters as the
same
as being undecided voters in essence it
adds so much more volatility where if
you have a race where we have a third
party candidate pulling it at 10% you
know there's a lot more uncertainty
there if we have a three-way race and in
2016 then it's gonna be the hard to
model
I'm Tiffany Washburn and I'm a PhD
student here in political science I was
a modeling analyst and the Obama
campaign so I a lot of what we've been
talking about so far as the presidential
election which is a very luxurious place
to be for a prediction market because
you have so many polls you have some
people who are interested so I'm just
wondering how your technology of choice
would do try to predict a smaller lower
information election like say the New
York mayoral race in general the further
you go down the ballot the less accurate
polling tends to be but there are some
nice things about working with
congressional elections which is that
you have you have a lot more data points
that are you know obviously you have
some correlation outcomes even in
congressional and Senate races but but
you know you can actually fit a model
that might have say six or seven
variables to think our Senate model does
and not have to worry about being being
overfit because you have 200 Senate
elections since 1990 or whatever instead
so in some ways it's more interesting
modeling problem although it's you know
you have to account for a larger margin
of error and general people have less
information to cite decide later in the
race you have you also have more
variance in candidate quality where you
know for example you had in the Delaware
Senate race to 2010 you had my castle
who would have won by by 10 points
replaced by Christine O'Donnell it's
kind of random literally crazy person
pretty much instead of an esteemed
representative and she lost by 15 points
instead whereas presidential nomination
process tends to filter out the nutcases
most of the time except you know Barry
Goldwater and but you know for the most
part for the most part you have pretty
good candidates running for for
president and so that means you don't
have to worry as much about about
candidate quality which are major issues
when you're facing congressional or
Senate races yeah I did I I'd like to
persuade this is a great opportunity
because there are so many congressional
races that you know I was saying before
you'll never be able to tell the
difference between 99 to lea
well if Phil would run a forecasting
contest between Nate and I where we have
to get each of the House races right
then we'll have a large enough sample
size will know something useful here now
why is it we don't see much polling at
the congressional district level because
it's expensive so I'm not particularly
optimistic the prediction markets are
going to be helpful the biggest problem
with prediction markets is getting
people to trade in them but the thing
I'm more excited about right now is this
idea of instead of running standard
polls asking people who they intend to
vote for asking them who they think will
win I believe that it that what my prior
on this is at the level of a
congressional district this would be a
very very powerful method because a
congressional district is all about
talking to people around the water
cooler seeing how many yard signs are
out there and so asking people in the
district who they think will win if we
get the same turbocharging effect that
we think we get which is every time you
ask someone who you think will win their
sort of responding based on a poll of
the ten other people around the water
cooler then even with very very small
samples at each congressional district
if we turbocharger by multiplying it by
ten we'll have effectively big enough
samples to say something useful so I
believe in 2012 my co-author and former
graduate student David Rothschild has
managed to persuade xboxone
to run some polls and the great thing
about that turns out lots of people play
xbox and they asked not only who you
intended to vote for but also who you
expected would win and I believe they
did it at the level of the congressional
district those data are sitting on
David's computer right now but we
hopefully in the next few months will be
crunchiness data and we'll actually be
able to say is this intuition right that
will actually be able to come up with
good forecasts at the level of a
congressional district just one small
story I went to Gallup with this idea
what you should do is ask people about
you know who you intend to vote for and
I said what you should do is just ask
this at a level the congressional
district and you know their response was
you know you know even at the end of the
campaign we're going to do 50 thousand
interviews over five honey Li 500
national districts so only 100 per
district so all you're gonna get is
noise and so this is pointless
to which my response was but if those
hundred people are each reporting on ten
others and you're getting an effective
sample size of a thousand per district
and which is it's great this is a low
loss proposition you either
first guys to get congressional district
polling right so I think or hope we'll
see some of that the next cycle okay we
started a little bit late so let's let's
go over another couple minutes and take
one last question by the way Justin I
hope your students going to correct for
the bias sample with the X Box
I'm told it's representative okay yes
over in the corner
so you've all spoke a lot about
predicting an election from the outside
can you give us some flavor of how the
insiders people working for parties are
using these techniques and whether they
are using them to tailor candidate
choice and basically product choice for
the candidates themselves Thanks
you know I would think that the insiders
who are adding the most value are
working with different types of data so
they're working with individual level
results we're kind of the Obama campaign
simplify basically has a model of
supposedly every every registered voter
in the country where they have two
numbers which is one on a 300 scale how
likely are they to vote for Obama or the
Republican and one how lucky are they to
vote period and there's a lot of model
that goes into that if you look at for
example the data set from the 2008 exit
polls and you have 50,000 actual voters
between the different states that were
surveyed so you can you can you know
it's a much richer data set than just
looking at top-line numbers instead I
personally the campaigns and
presidential election cycles don't
really benefit all that much from doing
their own polling really this is one
this case where you like literally could
kind of just trust the public polls in
most cases but but they also have
accessed a lot of individual lovely we
can identify relationships and yeah it's
possible to make you know to pick up on
some noise in that as well and you can
overfit models and make other types of
mistakes but they have access to a lot
more information than you get just by
looking at it at the top numbers from
the Gallup poll or whatever I just make
two observations so one is a lot of the
polling they're doing it's not actually
polling in the sense of trying to come
up with a forecast they want to know
which houses should we call on the week
before the election and if they've
called you three months earlier and
found out you're a staunch Democrat then
that's not forecasting that's knowing in
the second observation I am NOT inside
campaigns enough to answer precisely
your question which is how do they use
forecasts but I talk to a lot of people
in the corporate world and I think the
single best way of summarizing that is
almost all corporations completely
ignore all forecasts and if any of you
have an analyst role within a
corporation you can actually run the
experiment which is you know come up
with a crazy high forecast next month
and the following month to come up with
low forecasts and I bet nothing will
change and so this in some sense comes
back to the earlier question which is
it's surprising time and again when I
talk to executives how little of a truth
orientation they have the careers can be
made by wearing the right suit and
having the right cut of you know the
right having the right tie and they're
very rarely destroyed by bad forecasts
it's an interesting question how much
role there is for expert judgment in a
world that is becoming as data rich as
our world Nate mentioned the problems
with the UK election for example you
could in principle have had polls that
asked that that probe more deeply into
where the Liberal Democratic vote was
going to go conservative retort or
Labour and to various conditions but
it's very very hard to anticipate all
the contingencies that arise in election
campaign and and and to work them into
surveys and survey experiments and get
and get and get feedback in a timely way
so inevitably there is some role for for
expert judgment we have to you have to
make your make assumptions about where
things things are going to go and there
I think the parties would be well
advised to check how well calibrated
their experts are what one interesting
thing about political judgment that's
emerged in the IR / tournament is that
immunity often hear it said that that
that political experts are experts in
general are overconfident but when you
create composites of expert judgment the
composites often seem to be somewhat on
the under-confident side so if you have
four or five experts you know each of
whom has independent grounds for
believing that the probability of a
shift is 0.6 point six point seven point
six point six when you combine that it
turns out the best bet the best way to
use that information in political
forecasting is too extreme eyes which i
think is consistent with what with what
with what made does and and but that
gives a big boost to to accuracy
okay so I think we should wrap up at
this point
the panel certainly held up to my
predictions about how entertaining it
would be I hope you all enjoyed it as
much as I did
sincere thanks to all three of you just
until then and Nate were going to serve
on it and I believe there is a reception
outside that everyone is invited to so
we can continue the conversation over
there and I guess I'll just leave you
with a quote that I dug up from the
modern-day soothsayer Yogi Berra who
apparently said that prediction is very
hard especially about the future thank
you